uh the second talk of the session we
have jess banks uh jess is i think a
student here currently yesterday yeah i
don't know how it can be because jess
has been doing awesome work for so many
years um
but yeah uh just here to talk about
reputation especially quiet planting of
cuts and colorings in random graphs take
away jess thanks
fat introduction and of course the
invitation to speak so
um i've been following along with the
workshop remotely for the last couple
days so it's very nice to be here in the
flesh with you all
um this is some joint work with the
fonzo bandera tim kadiski christopher
moore and alex wine three of whom were
obviously lucky enough to have in the
room today
um and
i promised
cuts in random wraps and instead i'm
just going to tell you about colorings
because you know time is precious here
on this earth um
so uh let's
get moving
um
okay uh as usual in life we have a null
model uniformly random d regular graphs
for the next half hour
we have a planted model
which i'm not going to commit to the
specifics of but it's just some
k-colorable distribution over
the regular random graphs
i know that these little things are
going to be wiggling around the screen i
just want you to know that i know and it
bothers me as much as it's going to
bother you
um so the the talk today is about the
interplay between two different uh
algorithmic problems related to these
two different models
one is decision telling them apart and
the other is reputation
which doesn't care about the planted
model at all and just uh is trying to
prove that the null model is not
k-colorable
um so as we've heard a lot already this
week these problems are quite related
and in particular you know in general if
i have an algorithm that can refute the
existence of k colorings
it also gives me a decision algorithm
that works
to distinguish the null model from
actually any planted model i care to
choose so long as we're in a regime
where the null model is not capable of
high probability
so um
you know we've heard lots of great
techniques for proving hardness of
decision
this week and
the point here is that all those types
of evidence also can give you evidence
of hardness of reputation
but that this requires that you be a
little bit choosy about which planted
model you talk about so you want to
choose a quietly planted model one
that's hard to distinguish from the null
model and that will give you better
evidence for hardness of refutation
so that's what we're going to do today
we're going to design a computationally
quiet plant model
and
give a little bit of evidence for
hardness of
hardness of decision um
and in the paper that i'm talking about
we talked about some very basic kinds of
evidence for
hardness of decision we just like
computed the test and stigma threshold
very simple thing to do um and uh we
also studied this local statistics
hierarchy which was introduced in a
paper of mine with siddhant who's in the
audience and prasad who i think is not
um but is
so the idea is it's like a semi-definite
programming hierarchy for decision
problems um that is uh indebted to all
of the lovely work on pseudo calibration
and some of squares
that many folks in this room have worked
on
okay so that was the stuff in the paper
um and
just to make things simple for the talk
today i'm actually going to do something
even more basic
let's just think about when can you
plant a cake coloring in the d regular
random graph so it doesn't mess up the
spectrum so spectrum looks like a
uniformly random irregular graph so i'll
just remind you this is what the
spectrum of a deregular random graph
looks like
there's some eigenvalues which are kind
of confined to this interval between
minus 2 or d minus 1 and 2 or d minus 1.
there's a trivial eigenvalue of d and
there's basically nothing else
okay
so
this is the plan any questions about
this
okay so i'm contractually obligated to
show a phase diagram so here it is um so
you know here's d here's k when
k is big enough both decision and
refutation are impossible because the
null model is just k colorable with high
probability
on the other hand when k is sufficiently
small less than around root d over two
refutation is easy you can do kind of a
spectral refutation thing which i'll
tell you about on the next slide
um and so there's this big kind of wedge
in the middle here where we think
reputation might be hard and um the
whole game today is going to be to give
some evidence that that's the case
okay but first just to get us all
limbered up how does spectral refutation
work
um
well here's how it works so let me
define this quantity
mck which is like the normalized max k
cut in the graph okay
um just the maximum over all labeling
the vertices of the you know fraction of
edges that have different labels
um so if mck is equal to one the graph
is k colorable uh if it's less than one
it's not
so there's um some work of hoffmann and
the 70 is that you can kind of
retcon into being an upper bound on this
max k cut
here's what the upper bound looks like
you get this down kind of in terms of
the smallest eigenvalue of the adjacency
matrix
and
let's just remind ourselves how this
works
so let's say i have some partition of
the vertices into k groups and i'm going
to define this matrix p sigma sigma is
the name of the partition
um it's you know indexed by the pairs of
vertices in the graph and um you know
the uv entry for vertices u and v is one
if the labels are the same and it's
minus one over k minus one if the labels
are different
um
it's a psd matrix it has trace n
um it has some other nice properties
and now
just by glancing at this you might
imagine that
the inner product between this matrix
and the adjacency matrix
will tell you something about how many
edges are cut by this partition and
indeed it's true
so here is how you write mck in terms of
these p sigma matrices
and because p sigma is positive definite
and has trace n you can bound this from
above by this smallest eigenvalue of the
graph
questions here
great we're cruising
um so
okay how do you use this to uh you know
get an upper bound on mck for the
planted model well this is the kind of
thing you get
and you get it just by combining this
hoffman's theorem from the previous
slide with friedman's theorem about
where the eigenvalues the adjacency
matrix the random irregular graph lie
in particular that the smallest one is
at most
2 root d minus 1 plus a little bit of
extra stuff in absolute value
and so of course this
rules out k colorability whenever this
right hand side is less than 1 which
happens when k is around d over
2 root d minus 1. okay so
that's the story of this bottom line in
the phase diagram
and
so now we actually have to start
thinking about what's going on in the
middle here and i promised at the
beginning that we would you know
generate some evidence for hardness of
reputation by studying different
decision problems with different planted
models
so let's first see what happens if you
take the very boring garden variety
planted cake coloring model
which i'll remind you the specifics of
on the next slide so what happens is
that when k is around root d
that's the like easy hard transition for
um distinguishing these two models
so above there we think that
decision is hard which supplies some
evidence that refutation is hard
and below it we think that decision is
easy in fact we know so because you can
just do it using the spectrum i'll say
why that is in a second
but the point is that this leaves open
this whole kind of lower wiggly triangle
here
where this planted model is not
supplying any evidence for hardness of
reputation
and so to design a better one let's see
why this one fails to do it why it's not
spectrally quiet
in this range so here's how this model
works in case you forgot
i start off by dividing the vertices
into some different groups
and i just sample a deregular random
graph conditional on there being no
internal edges to each of those groups
so condition on those groups being a
valid coloring
and if you look at the spectrum of one
of these things
what you'll find is that it kind of
looks like the spectrum of a random
deregular graph so there's this bulk of
eigenvalues between these two familiar
numbers there's this trivial one at d
but then as soon as k is less than root
d
a bunch of eigenvalues leave the book
sad
so you can just look for these things
and easily distinguish
okay um
so to kind of give some intuition for
why this is happening
let's take a detour into another weird
world of continuous probability
[Music]
and think about uh you know
the following problem
so let's say i want to design the
gaussian random matrix um
whose spectrum looks kind of like a
wigner matrix so it has this usual
semi-circle distribution
but i've pre-selected a vector v and a
number lambda kind of close to the lower
edge of the spectrum
and i want this quadratic form to be
around lambda for my pre-selected vector
v okay
so how do i do this
well one option is i just sample a
bigger matrix and i spike it with a rank
one matrix
but you shouldn't do this
or rather you shouldn't expect that
he'll be quiet because there's some uh
work from about 15 years ago that says
that as soon as lambda gets
close enough to the bottom end of the
spectrum
this thing ejects an eigenvalue that
lets you tell it apart from a bigger
matrix
um so that's a bummer but
luckily there is a different thing you
can do
um which is the following so again you
can sample a bigner matrix um but
instead of just kind of doing this like
crass at a rank one matrix thing
um what you're gonna do is
you know go to your number lambda that
you want um the eigenvalues of this
bigger matrix you sampled are pretty
nicely distributed in this interval
minus two to two so you can find one
lambda hat that's approximately lambda
and it'll have some eigenvalue
eigenvector rather v hat
and now you're gonna set your
planted matrix x to be u times w times u
star where u is a unitary matrix that
maps v hat to v in other words you're
going to rotate things
so that v hat is actually an eigenvector
sorry v is actually an eigenvector of
the sampled matrix
and you know this is great because of
course the spectrum is the same as the
matrix you started with you just rotated
by a unitary but now you've guaranteed
that this quadratic form is exactly what
you wanted so this is a nice observation
by uh alfonso tim and alex from a little
while ago and the lesson here
is that
if you're going to quietly plant some
signal and some matrix it's good if you
can arrange things so that signal is
itself an eigenvector
and you know there's a very
nice way to do this in the continuous
case when everything is kind of
rotationally invariant and you can just
pick this unitary
but you know what are we going to do
in the case of deregular random graphs
where things are much more like
combinatorial and brittle okay well i'll
tell you what we're going to do
we're going to look at random lifts
so
there is a lot of nice technical
mathematical stuff you can say here but
let me just tell you
the you know
layman's version of a random lift so
let's start with some graph h here it is
maybe it has some multiple edges that's
okay
um let's also assume it's k colorable
although you don't need it to be to do
this random lifting thing and now to
make
our random d regular graph g
we're going to blow up each of these
vertices of h to a big cloud of vertices
and for each edge of this base graph h
we're going to add a random perfect
matching between
each of the clouds of vertices so if
there's multiple edges then we'll add
multiple
matchings if not we'll just add one
and
there's a couple of important things to
say about this one is that if h is
k-colorable g is k-colorable too right
because you can just lift the coloring
up from the small graph to the big one
okay the other nice thing is that
locally this graph g looks exactly like
h so every blue vertex is connected to
two pink ones and one yellow one
etc
and because of these properties
[Music]
you can
you can show that all of the eigenvalues
of h actually lift to eigenvalues of g
so this is kind of neat
and moreover
it is a consequence of a much bigger and
badder theorem by boardmap and collins
from a couple of years ago
that all the rest of the eigenvalues of
this random lift g look exactly like a
graph from the null model
so you know in other words if you look
at the spectrum of g there are going to
be some eigenvalues these yellow ones
coming from the base graph and then
everything else is just this usual shape
that we have
so
um all of that is to say that as long as
the eigenvalues of h are inside this
interval as long as h is ramanujan
then this model is spectrally quiet its
spectrum looks more or less like the
spectrum of a uniformly random irregular
graph
okay
any questions about this
so
um
this is going to be our like planted
model our quietly planted model and now
we just have to study this for various
choices of the spacecraft h
so in the paper that is the subject of
this talk we picked a very simple kind
of base graph h
so let's assume that k minus 1 divides d
and let's just take h to be
a graph with k vertices
and
a bunch of multi edges between each pair
of
those k vertices
so that there's the same number of
multi-edges um between each pair okay
so
this
um if you take a random lift of this it
goes by another name um in fact many
other names in the literature it's kind
of annoying the equitable gas clock
model or the regular stochastic block
model or the whatever there's everyone
calls it a different thing
but the property is that um you know
each of these
vertices that arises from a blue vertex
is connected to exactly the same number
of all other types of vertices
so it's kind of equitably
you know whatever it's equitable i guess
um
and in our paper we show a couple things
about this model so in addition to it
being spectrally quiet
we show that whenever k minus 1 divides
z and k is larger than this familiar
number from before
a couple of things happen so one is that
you know the trivial fixed point of bp
is stable so in other words this is like
the test and sigmund threshold for this
model
we also show that low-degree local
statistics which is this sdp hierarchy
that i mentioned but did not explain
before
fails to solve this distinguishing
problem between this planted model and
the null model so this is some kind of
rudimentary evidence for hardness of
distinguishing
um
so
this is kind of neat
but of course this model is only defined
for certain values of k and d right so
going back to this um
region of interest here all these blue
dots are places where like
uh k minus one divides d and so you know
if d has lots of um factors then there's
lots of k's for which this could happen
but if like d is a prime number then um
this model isn't defined and so we
actually haven't provided any evidence
for hardness of reputation because there
is no quietly planted model to speak of
so the question is like what's going on
for other values of d
like
when d is prime or d is small or
whatever
um
and um so what we're working on now
since we're among friends i'll tell you
about some work in progress
um
so
the claim is that if h is any deregular
k-colorable romination graph
then the same two things as the
four-hole the trivial fixed point of vp
is stable
and um you know low-degree local
statistics fails to distinguish these
two things
um so this would provide some more
evidence that for lots of other values
of d something is going on with hardness
of refutation
and so motivated by this let me make a
conjecture the conjecture is this
um this condition of there being a
deregular k-colorable ramune graph is
exactly what is controlling hardness of
refutation for this problem so whenever
there's a dnk for which one of these
things exists then it's hard to refute
and if there's not
then it's easy to refute um
so
if you know anything about ramanujan
wraps this should disturb you a little
bit because they're notoriously
difficult objects to study or to prove
the existence or non-existence of
so i think it's quite striking actually
that they're showing up in this problem
of refuting colorings and uh random
theoretical graphs
um
so
i'll leave you with that conjecture and
then just a couple of things that either
i or even better you all should do
i'm surprised no one uh shouted this out
but
i'm cheating a little bit with this
planted model because um although the
spectra look the same between it and the
null model
you can tell the two apart just by
looking at all the eigenvectors because
in fact the eigenvectors of the small
graph lift eigenvectors of the big graph
that have a very specific structure and
so okay
what's up with that well
um maybe you can just flip like linearly
many edges and this will go away
this also happens in lots of other
situations right where things like sum
of squares can't see things like this
like gaussian elimination succeeds but
we also think the problem is kind of
hard or whatever
okay so someone should maybe study this
model um
you know it would be good to give other
evidence more you know substantial
evidence that decision is hard between
this planted model and the null model um
in particular i don't know higher degree
local statistics or like low degree
polynomials um although these are both
pretty notoriously challenging in this
case with the regular graphs
um
on the other hand it would be good to
just study other refutation algorithms
like higher degree sos or other types of
improvements to hoffman's bound this is
something we're thinking about as well
and then finally i think the most
interesting
next question is how do you do this in
the case of like
non-regular graphs so let's say you
wanted to quietly plant
a coloring
in a sparse air to [ __ ] graph how
would you do so
um because there's there's no natural
analog of this like random lift in that
case
and so it i think is
um a really nice question and i'm not
quite sure how to answer it
okay so there's lots of homework for all
of you um i hope to see the assignments
on my desk soon and with that i will go
back to the title slide and take some
questions
[Applause]
yes
sure so on the last point about
urge running graphs um
does the lower bound work on earth's
ring drops
um the
the hoffmann
so you can do a different thing that
involves looking at the spectrum of the
non-backed engagements
um but because the adjacency matrix of
variation just like sparse graphs looks
kind of
smeared out along the edges that
specifically doesn't work but there is
another special recognition
this construction applies for larger
flagelli like the going weapon
yeah it's a good question i haven't
thought
this is this conjecture that you
mentioned about hardness when like there
exists or doesn't exist
that's
up to a factor of two right like
things are still
okay um
how do you mean
the the the threshold for reputation
that you talked about is
trying to improve this background or
yeah that's right the conjecture is that
literally if i fix some value of d and i
want to know which values of k
one can um
easily versus not easily repeat k
volatility right that it suffices to
check
exercises to check whether their dozer
does not exist
so there doesn't exist one i mean okay
proving that there is no point now in
some algorithm okay we're not gonna talk
about that
but if there does not exist around the
thinking graph you have any faint idea
of how to turn that into an algorithm
yeah so i mean
in in some sense in some abstract sense
so you know um
let's say you look at all possible
deregular k colorable graphs
and you look at
workspace
so you know um
here's a minus two root d minus one
let's say you look at all possible the
regular uh k portable graphs and you
look at where their smallest eigenvalue
is
so let's punch down here
um if there's some separation between
this and minus two d minus one and you
actually prove that like you approve a
lower bound on
you know how far to the right these
land domains go then that gives you a
reputation of whether you just check
whether your graph has an eigenvalue
smaller than that
so it it's not a crazy notion that this
could actually be components i mean
there's lots of weird potential cases
where like
you know there's no wrong nutrition
graph but there are ones arbitrarily
close
i don't know
i should say there are similar results
for like
uh large k-way cuts
[Music]
okay let's think just once more
uh let me remind everybody that tomorrow
afternoon michael celantano is leading a